les vacances d'été vous semble peut-être
encore un peu loin et pourtant la
préfecture des yvelines vous engage à
les anticiper pour éviter l'afflux de
demandes et des délais allongés pour
obtenir la carte d'identité passeport
vérifier dès à présent les dates
d'expiration vous pouvez déposer une
demande dans les trois mois qui
précèdent cette date au rendez vous
ensuite dans l'une des 35 mairies du
département équipées de stations
biométriques la liste des mairies et sur
le site et villepin gouv.fr le délai
idéal pour être sûr d'obtenir vos
documents un mois et demi avant votre
date de départ où votre date d'examen